ragazzi avete presente tipo i giochi
quelli con grafica mozzafiato trama
epica gameplay fantastico cioè roba
assurda
ecco perfetto questo gioco non lo è ma
proprio un cazzo
prima di cominciare ragazzi quale
qualsiasi in frase di chiama nel
videogame voi immaginate la come se
fosse a sfondo sessuale
capirete presto il perché era tutti
ragazzi e prendendo questo nuovo video
sono fa vj e la gestiamo su barbie
[Musica]
non c'è
[Applauso]
cosa sto facendo della mia vita
siamo sub arbitri non spartire che anche
se è probabilmente è stato eletto il
gioco dell'anno
di sicuro non ho idea del perché così
tanti mi abbiate chiesto di fare proprio
questo perché evidentemente sarà figo
direi che possiamo iniziare perché non
vedo l'ora di scoprirlo tatro una donna
che facciamo questo c'è uno sguardo del
tipo mi chiamarono costretto non volevo
che anche ragazzi dire che siccome
barbie sta continuando a guardarsi le
unghia il cane probabilmente ha già
pagato a terra direi che possiamo
iniziare per natura extra e le bellezze
di questo capolavoro videoludico i già
utilizza la funzione di autosalvataggio
questi con indica che salvataggi in
corso madonna che tecnologia avanzata
perfetto
direi che possiamo iniziare la gara che
cosa star di questo già muovere non
spiega un cazzo tutorial 0 tu sei già
giocare a prescindere da ciao bello come
saiwa una scappatella vizio di premi in
qualche modo se non è spera che barbie
gliela dia in un modo o nell'altro ma
tagliare questo caso tu sei pronto per
giocare ma certo se ci sei anche tu sarà
di sicuro uno sballo il dialogo più
fantastico che abbia mai sentito giura
comunque ragazzi cosa devo fare i
precisi sto gioco fanta guardaroba
riguarda la posso vestirmi che possa
addirittura a cambiarmi vestiti ragazzi
questo non me lo aspettavo così
fantastico
c'è allora vediamo di mettere ecco
perfetto così da squadrina perfetto
questo mi piace meno chiacchiere che
così sono molto più [ __ ] quindi possiamo
andare è una cosa c'è addirittura il
guardaroba ragazzi sa cosa non me
l'aspettavo veramente passi da gigante
nei videogiochi diamo di sopra e chiesa
tizia brutta [ __ ] queste sono le mie
scale che ci fai qui per cominciare a
giocare
si no prima che si fanno le cose a tre
ma che schifo ragazzi qualcuno ti poi mi
mi spiega perchè sto giocando a sta roba
no perché io non l'ho ancora capito
effettivamente prendendo la mano
sentite stavano giocando i videogiochi
allora devo scegliere una devo scegliere
una stanza per andava alla camera di
barbie iniziamo da questa perché mi
sembra ispezione alla stanza per trovare
l'oggetto sfida sono prontissimo per
questa avventura mozzafiato è una cosa
allora devo trovare nelle scarpe va bene
allora cerchiamo le scarpe a bello
posso cambia ma basta cambiarsi i
vestiti ha rotto le balle
la faccia ce la facciamo a trovare stami
che cosa devo trovare scarpe come faccio
a trovare sia perfetto tanto devo
metterli in ordine hanno capito come
ecco perfetto questa la messa lì questa
la messa lì per verso un fenomeno
ragazzi a trovare scarpe in si giochi
d'azione io sono solo il numero uno non
c'è verso
ho vinto scarpe cielo portati a destra
sinistra per prendere le scatole che
cadono ok va bene devo prendere le
scatole lo zio veramente le mie domande
sono due allora uno chi è che ha
ordinato tutta sta roba da zalando
fatemi capire e la seconda ragazzi
marchi e che sta lanciando 400 scatole
dal soffitto fatemi capire infatti sono
domande che premente non avranno mai
risposta e nemmeno ci tengo tanto ad
averla va bene così se stronze sono
forti [ __ ] ecco l'effetto finito
[ __ ] tutte quante che ho fatto
regali preciso perché ho paura del
risultato ma va bene ok ok merda ultimo
grandioso e non so mai questi giochi di
guerra c'è competizione capitemi è
sbloccato uomini joe kelly che figo
impazziscono per le calzature
basta avere un buon paio di scarpe da
ginnastica o se anche delle scarpe da
skate e le infradito
giuro che prendo le scarpe una ad una
tela infilo su per il culo
e così sono i giochi fantastico e cioè
un gioco molto vario stand distrutto piu
velocemente negli avversari per vincere
ma io non so truccarmi come cazzo faccio
cioè se qualcuno mi allora fatemi capire
io devo devo truccarmi così c'è questo
questo è il gioco più bello che abbia
mai facile spiegatemi il senso la mia
professionalità in questo campo è
qualcosa di invidiabile questo ve lo
dico erano sette ragazzi so per voi oggi
faccio il make up artist quindi vi
insegna a fare make up prima di tutto
ragazzi si applica un rossetto molto
bello si applica
in modo abbondante diciamo coerente
ragazzi si deve applicare anche sotto
perché soltanto un labbro poi è brutto
quindi chiamare un casinò a devo fare
ok non sono anche giochi non so neanche
truccarmi fantastico dopo di che i
ragazzi si spazzola con questa fare qua
come se cercassimo delle parti
archeologici quindi si fa tipo tipo
scavatura perfetto ragazzi state attenti
perché se cosa vi torneranno utili un
giorno è finita ringraziando iddio fatto
13 punti 13 [ __ ] tutti i 13
abbiamo fatto tutti lo stesso punteggio
grandi vera che batte il cinque ragazze
siamo troppo trendy per che cazzo sta
iniziando a parlare così ti giuro che mi
stanno cadendo i maroni ma in una
maniera credo non mi sia mai successo
così brutta [ __ ] de sbaglia di una
cosa devi fare deficiente viene così da
vomitare per il rosa che hanno usato
fantastico ancora volte basta hai rotto
i [ __ ] sfida di ballo e semi passi
lance no no questo no questo no no ho
preparato una sfida danzante per le
ragazze che si chiama all'ultimo ballo i
ragazzi stiamo stiamo scendendo nel
ridicolo questi sono i passi di danza
più belli che io abbia mai visto in vita
mia credetemi ragazzi guardate la
funzion da velocità raddoppiata perché è
bellissimo
[Musica]
sono veramente allibito da che cosa si
sono inventati st c'è veramente 196 ho
fatto ti è zoppo le guarda
l'ultima volta che ho visto gli altri
muoversi così è stato quando a stessi
sono scappate le formiche dal formicaio
non valga 0 ed ora c'è la créme che qui
minigiochi pensavo che fossimo arrivati
al limite più assoluto ma evidentemente
mi sbagliavo
devo lavare il didietro di un pony c'è
io ho più più di così non so veramente
sa fare della mia vita perché è un po
anni mi sta aiutando in faccia sentire i
denti teli la vida solo kay perché non è
che posso allora tu sei un cavallo
riprendi studenti frecce lavateli da
solo perché non ci sono io non lo faccio
ecco bryo questo dovete lo metto sul
pene ma vuoi che te lo metta ascom
schifo un perfetto di collo spillo
intero fu così anche vedere sto gioco mi
sono rotto i [ __ ]
giocarci tutto il giorno io no
sicuramente d'accordo ragazzi siccome
sono non so neanche spiegare che cosa ho
provato a giocare a questa roba di
preciso però va bene comunque ragazzi se
il video è piaciuto e se siete d'accordo
commenti questo gioco sia il più grande
action mai fatto nella storia lasciate
un commento mi piace ai georgiani
facebook e come non è venuto da tale
iscrizione senza vestiti scatena ci
vediamo al prossimo vinto da ragazzi